tired of the mcu hulk being kind of a
joke there's one story from the comics
that could bring out the devil in him
she-hulk also known as jennifer walters
has finally arrived in the marvel
cinematic universe and luckily for her
she has a hulk to teach her the ropes
although the disney plus series is very
much jennifer's story her cousin bruce
banner is also a key part of it at least
to start he's the reason she gets her
powers following a car accident not only
that a cecarian ship causes the crash in
the first place and it's clearly looking
for the green champion who once fought
on the planet as a gladiator so marvel
studios may be gearing up to take a stab
at the full world war hulk storyline
it's a car in class a courier craft
they're probably trying to deliver a
message i got to get to the bottom of
that
the hulk has become more of a comedic
character of late thanks to professor
hulk an adaptation of world war hulk
would help him get back his dark edge
but another would take things even
further writer al ewing and artist joe
bennett's a mortal hulk the series not
only takes a deep dive into what makes
bruce banner tick but it
re-contextualizes the hulk's powers his
origin and his place in the wider marvel
universe the story sees bruce as a nomad
who roams the united states while trying
to keep both hands on his mental
steering wheel ewing and bennett also
hold up a mirror to the ugliest parts of
society and how the hulk reckons with
humanity
the first issue sees the hulk hunt down
a man who accidentally kills a 12 year
old girl in a gas station robbery gone
wrong from there the stories only get
darker it essentially proposes the idea
that while banner can be killed the hulk
takes over at night resurrecting him if
he has to it also reveals that the
hulk's worst identity devil hulk has
become the most dominant personality
while the mcu has acknowledged banner's
trouble balancing his personality over
the years
it has never relished in letting the
hulk loose he got to smash bad guys in
all the avengers movies but it's not the
same as having him run wild and what
better way to let him off the chain than
by analyzing his psyche in a dark
intense story the only problem with
adapting a mortal hulk is the stunning
body horror that al ewing and joe
bennett weave throughout their series
it's impressive that marvel let the duo
get away with some of the most grotesque
imagery on the page for example there's
the infamous moment involving the
abomination in immortal hulk number 18.
although hulk assumes that it's emil
blonsky the monster looks different
because his head looks like a closed
fist it's actually two closed fists and
when they unfurl they reveal the two
distorted faces of former hulk sidekick
rick jones who's been experimented on by
a nefarious organization it's a truly
grim revelation and it's just one of
many violent designs that pop up over
the course of the series although the
mcu has dabbled in horror with the likes
of the doctor strange movies depicting
graphic gamma-induced transformations
and breakdowns might be too far for the
house of mouse but with some clever
concessions marvel studios could still
bring the story to life after all if
scarlet witch can ruthlessly slaughter
the illuminati and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness there's a way of
showing the rick jones abomination mcu
had kevin feige confirmed at san diego
comic con 2022 that the current era of
the mcu is titled the multiverse saga
building towards avengers the kang
dynasty and avengers secret wars an
immortal hulk movie could absolutely fit
into that frame a huge part of the story
revolves around the idea that there's a
terrifying realm that lurks at the very
bottom of the multiverse
i'm sorry you're saying there's a
multiverse
and it's growing in immortal hulk the
below place is essentially hell for
anyone who's been transformed by gamma
radiation people who have been there can
come back from the dead and they won't
remember their time there it's ruled by
a cruel force called the one below all
who is hell-bent on wiping out all life
in the multiverse essentially this
terrifying entity can possess most gamma
irradiated monsters as a host although
the hulk eventually manages to cut it
off from the rest of the multiverse so
an immortal hulk movie would introduce a
new realm of existence just like chongqi
loki doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness and thor love and thunder
have so not only could an immortal hulk
movie slot perfectly into the current
direction of the mcu but it would
deliver a completely fresh take on hulk
and bruce banner
[Music]
you